pause the video and try to add these two
rational expressions
okay i'm assuming you've had a go at it
now we can work through this together so
the first thing that you might have hit
when you tried to do it is you realize
that they have different denominators
and it's hard to add fractions when they
have different denominators you need to
rewrite them so that you have a common
denominator and the easiest way to get a
common denominator is you can just
multiply the two denominators especially
in a case like this where they don't
seem to share any factors both of these
are about as factors you can get and
they don't share anything in common
and so let's set let's set up a common
denominator so this is going to be equal
to
it's going to be equal to
something let's see it's going to be
equal to something over our common
denominator let's make it
let's make it 2x let me just add another
color
so we're going to make it 2
x minus 3
times 3x plus 1
times
3x plus 1
and then plus
plus something else
over
2x minus 3
times 3x plus 1
times 3x
plus 1.
and so to go from 2x to go from just a
2x minus 3 here in the denominator to a
2x3
times 3x plus 1 we multiply the
denominator by 3x plus 1. so if we do
that to the denominator we don't want to
change the value of the rational
expression we'd have we'd also have to
do that to the numerator so the original
numerator was 5
x
in that blue color
so the original numerator was 5x
and now we're going to multiply it by
the 3x plus 1. so times 3x plus 1.
notice i didn't change the value of this
expression i multiply it by 3x plus 1
over 3x plus 1 which is 1 as long as as
long as 3x plus 1 does not equal 0. so
let's do the same thing over here
over here
over here i have a denominator of 3x
plus 1
i multiplied it by 2x minus 3 so i would
take my numerator which is negative 4x
squared
and i would also multiply it by 2x minus
3.
2x
minus 3. let me put parentheses around
this so it doesn't look like i'm
subtracting 4x squared
and so then i can rewrite all of this
business as being equal to
well in the numerator
in the numerator i'm going to have
5x times 3x which is 15
x squared
5x times 1 which is plus 5x
and then over here let me do this in
green
let's see i could do 4x times 2 negative
4x times 2x which would be negative 8 x
squared and then negative 4x times
negative 3 which is plus 12
x squared did i do that right negative
oh let me be very careful negative
negative 4 i in my spider sense could
tell that i did something shady
in fact if you want to pause the video
you could see try to figure out what i
just did that's wrong so negative 4x
squared times 2x is negative 8x to the
third power
negative 8x to
the third power
and then negative 4x squared plus times
negative 3 is 12x squared
and then our entire denominator
our entire denominator we have a common
denominator now so we were able to just
add everything
is 2x minus 3
2x minus 3 times 3x plus 1
times 3x plus 1. and let's see how can
we simplify this so this is all going to
be equal to
let me draw
make sure we recognize it's a rational
expression and so let's see we can look
at
we can we our highest degree term here
is the negative 8x to the third so it's
negative 8
x to the third power
and then we have a 15 x squared and we
also have a 12 x squared we could add
those two together to get a 27
x squared so we've already taken care of
this
we've taken create let me do that green
color so we've taken care
of this taking care of those two and
we're just left with a 5x
so plus
5x
and then all of that is over
2x
minus 3
times 3x plus 1
ex plus 1
and we are
all done it doesn't seem like there's
any easy way to simplify this further
you could factor out an x out of the
numerator but that's not going to cancel
out with anything in the denominator and
it looks like we are all done